hey there reject nation look who's here
with me today
Tara Ericsson you got my name right this
is Gregory Alba you've been on my
brother's channel Jobbik away right yep
yep right the Indian community loves you
I think they do I don't know I don't
know I don't know looser version of Tara
here really get loose on this sad this
is out of the able train I mean his last
name is an Alba
that's Kawai he legally changed it like
my bad we have a lot more of Indian
subscriber following than before and of
course that leads to a lot of requests I
was talking on my brother out there you
know what I feel like do I feel like
covering some short films from India
they recommended me three him and Achara
and today I'm we're gonna do this one
call I excuse me for saying it wrong I
don't know how to pronounce most things
even in English
sure Cherie Cherie Cherie Cherie
probably history probably the best that
right there they recommended me three in
a Chara said this is her personal
favorite one okay
so I said you know what I'm gonna cover
this one with Tara what's doing ready to
watch a short film no I'm excited I love
short film I don't know what this is but
shorter that's what it is sure to put
that together this is a really long trip
to pick this back here's me talk
[Music]
okay
large large to large short large the
eastern way snap is he having an affair
yeah sneaky business led to some sort of
video the way he was really happy about
that her people
oh I feel like he was also playing with
his wedding ring while you were saying
this like he wasn't gonna take him to
subtle undertones
oh boy
Snickers yeah
okay
man so the dad's being a dick and she's
saying about the mom yeah Oh God
yeah for sure oh yeah the double life
oh god she's gonna find him she's gonna
go in there cuz it was set up that she
can't do anything but she can't do
everything the lips not just thick the
stairs up there she's gonna be exhausted
when she gets up there it's gonna be
hard to come from it's gonna be hard to
end it how did how does she know BRE is
my phone tracking maybe she just has
known this whole time I think so yeah
she's gonna be like I've known 40 years
now it's setup she's not gonna be gone
where she has her own affair maybe you
think so I don't know
[Music]
[Music]
this is uncomfortable my aloe vera so
much better looking than yeah oh my god
[Music]
I'm fascinated by how this was like yeah
[Music]
spray yourself down grease no like you
don't need to put that on
[Music]
hiya
oh they know each other yeah they're
friends oh [ __ ] probably a freaking
sister like younger yeah just give her
water in the doorway yeah welcome her
walking all those
those of me I find it wah ha whoa
five minutes last during Korean mr.
Saladino my celibacy at a 2d video
Zealand be Thank You Buster ara yes
she's looking at the birds from the
beginning
I hope this [ __ ] gets got yeah
me too
I'm sure militia to be facility see me
oh I think I see a little bar over there
is no heating sure
no name isn't it man if you're gonna
have affairs you got to be better at
lying
yeah like don't be so much she knows it
arrangement correctly how's that huh but
party get into Sigma energy goes 7ku
subcostal Hey
shut up today about the who become a
dying basically signify that a single
rose I know I know excitement for a
second Buddhahood crude into Wednesday
Ghana to us are not cutting into subsets
was a harsh I do not think I said but
joke in Monday always to go to some
translate that something huh so we
already quit probably because every
Monday night then
middle monday committee dance class with
me here or very stay cold yoga class
with god she gonna kill her
so she's gonna stab my dad's just tried
it yeah haha so that's our classical
junkie his name's I mean was it wait
she's just a mid to the affair don't
even like choke will do so elocution
wrote me a nice table to see me up
Tuesday Thursday somebody audience
Sunday arsenic is the something to [ __ ]
you Karina extra Sunday I think you
Sunda fight the problem is and think
about chillin I mean no one wants them
[Music]
damn this around
uh-huh the conquer this then becomes
available was interpreted the horizon
together soldered on
we oh geez
with high quality jobs - a laptop semi
right Jim Jonathan about you have to
pretty Cucaracha damn you know what's on
it
dude she might have just like completely
dismantle that affair uh yeah yeah who
the heck is Vikram oh don't call that
gosh
what god she's gonna come out see him
Wow he's smart cookie I really wanted to
like walk him out with the kids she can
[Music]
know what that word means cheering okay
that's it
commercial commercial well while these
credits are rolling whoa see uh if I
could how do you spell that Cherie yes I
should have just looked it up in my
phone but I didn't Indian spicy dish
made from yogurt buttermilk and Chili's
okay often eaten with roasted meats it
was a refreshing supplement to a variety
of spicy dishes
all right well Ishikawa Kapiti and
really learn the history of the it's
spicy just like they're fair and just
like his wife
oh it's meaning it's spicy yeah it's
okay I'll find the meaning and in words
you just read them aloud it's fine now
pull up all the dead weight here
appreciate it yeah that's what Tara does
yeah she fills in the gaps into that I
can yeah I don't think there's a post
credit scene doesn't seem like there's
one coming oh man I have been in that
situation one too many times really look
at you hiding in the closet oh yeah
hiding in the closet it's just women are
throwing themselves at me so often yeah
it's really hard you got a juggling
Friday you start getting too mixed up
are you all right ma'am one likes roses
the other likes yeah I don't know lilies
it mazes me how in like most movies and
shows people are just so bad at lying
oh yeah I get they're always so hard
obviously probably want it to be that
way
right yeah yeah there's gotta be a part
like this but at the beginning though
and he's looking at his phone oh yeah
just like um oh you were so having an
affair yeah yeah it was really obvious I
would have preferred it to keep it more
a secret in the beginning I thought it
was gonna be a flip like a
bait-and-switch words like it looks like
he's having an affair because he has a
smile but then it's something really
funny where he's like he's just going to
play like I don't know soccer or
something I don't know it would have
been a better move to be like oh yeah
silence it and then I don't know keep us
guessing other than that little nitpick
I thought this was really well-executed
because the way the reveals kept going
where you're like what's going on this
family
oh snap he's having an affair uh-huh and
then she's climbing the stairs like oh
she gonna be piss and murder some song
right and then the way she handled
dismantling this whole affair done in
such a way that I didn't expect coming
he is you picked up on - oh she actually
knows I thought she is she knows the
whole time she knows about this whole
thing and her even addressing I know
that if there's no secrecy it takes away
a lot of the fun of it all but right
then and there like oh she just teaches
completely dismantle this affair and
then bringing up the boss and then the
dad then the husband who taught her he
was shaved like oh what an [ __ ]
yeah like such terrible people these two
are I don't know I felt like most of the
time that's how it would have gone down
was the way I was predicting would go
down like finding him and then it all
blows out of chaos or whatever because I
thought about comedic music and tone was
a little weird I agree with you in in
where you said it turned into like a
sitcom that part yes but then when you
see how she's her approach to handling
it you're like yeah it's a vibe because
she's got a whole other kind of clever
planner personally that's what she
pointed out the birds she didn't
actually see that chime and it was like
let's go talk about it it's like she has
the exact same one she knows where this
girl got it from and decides to make a
point and make it more awkward to shove
it in her face
she knew he was there yeah yeah he must
have known mm-hmm the guy too is uh I
don't know maybe maybe home maybe their
country he's a very attractive man
yeah don't want to be mean but that
really but over the girlís weekend like
these two women though really
they're both beautiful it's like he just
doesn't seem that welcome but I love
that line of I'm glad he met you because
start coloring his hair and exercise
because so much of an affair the
excitement I imagine is from the fact
that how it's a secret you know whatever
but that you you take away the secrecy
you give kind of this like empowering
effective diminishes any level of
enthusiasm about right here and you
bring their shame to life I kind of
wonder what happened to the guy I mean
he has to walk down the street naked but
like it's the me is the marriage gonna
fall apart for reals now you know or is
he gonna leave the family or she get her
husband back you know I work where's
that gonna go because I think she takes
him back because she her whole point was
like you can have him but nobody
actually wants okay and that would take
away the secrecy right but also the like
love of the affair is that if she is he
if he's around too much secrecy and like
that level of like ooh I wonder like
what else there is to know about you is
gone because now he like lives there two
days a week I didn't know if that was
her just using as a manipulation ploy or
her tactic the wife to pretty much tear
this apart I think it's both okay
probably she's like my truth yeah that's
true there is the kids there is the kid
actor - in there that was your whole
point like but the kids the kid the kid
yeah that's cuz the the mistress this
woman was being portrayed as kind of the
villain of this story yes you know what
I'm like cool it's really the husband
who's the real villain right no no yeah
I agree it's it's his choice to like
step out on the marriage and she doesn't
the single girls not married she's just
doing another dude - that's her only
issue I think it's around man man I
would lock the husband out so quick I'd
be like you can see the kids at some
apartment that you buy two days a week
yeah oh I've been there my kids just
don't really see their dad in every
situation that you'll ever see it any
short film but he's been there done then
that's me that's that's the Greg yeah
the woman
I mean it's Monday through Friday
sometimes they bounced the weekend I
like to play against myself makes for an
unproductive week yes Lee you know right
probably probably get morale thing it's
a variety yeah I'm really productive you
know cuz on Tuesdays when Bryan comes
over I know that I have to shoot a
couple of videos cuz he takes a lot
longer than Matt on Wednesdays Matt on
Wednesdays quick point I need to only
shoot me one video edit then you know
there's certain days other other people
they take more time really it's helped
me regulate it's good getting really
good at scheduling if there's anything
take away from this mm-hmm
you should be if you're single yeah
woman you should be sleeping around as
much as you can for sure or if you're in
a relationship you should be having
affairs for sure I I got more from the
short film than I realized and you ever
have well in real life honestly amazing
cheering amazing stuff this is an
amplification of my personal life on
that note thank you guys for watching go
get Jerry go get Cherie Cherie
go get your eat in life if you guys are
new to Tara being here like if watching
a video with Tara this is how it goes
Tara leans here and I sit over here cuz
I'm like I can't be too comfortable with
Tara or else I look strange
so I'll just sit over here while Tara's
very comfortable you always look strange
whose rough living over here look at
that here what's he doing over here guys
you can subscribe to the reject nation
please click that notification Bell
check out Tara Erickson on our YouTube
channel and Instagram and whatever and
catching the flippety-flip